winter is coming and the world is not as
it once was children I don't know how
long this thing's gonna end up being
because honestly there's almost nothing
I can talk about that is the spoilers
this I just to say this was awesome I
love Game of Thrones I love Game of
Thrones since episode 1 but season
finales haven't necessarily been the
show strong point that's not to say that
any of the finales have really been
terrible but the show has generally done
it's real big moments all in the
second-to-last episodes that's where we
had execution of Ned Stark Battle of
Blackwater red wedding final episodes
and the seasons on the show have
generally been tying up loose ends not
this time this time of the show is
giving amazing resolutions to stuff that
we were all just dying to find out what
was gonna happen and it sets up so much
wonderful stuff for next season and next
season is gonna look so much different
than the show has up to this point I'm
so excited for that because for a show
that's claiming to tell a massive
continuous story it has to change and
evolve otherwise it just becomes
repetitious this show is definitely not
that like I said all the stuff I want to
really talk about it's all spoilers I
mean I suppose I can just single out
some stuff
Tyrion stuff fantastic Brienne of Tarth
amazing Arya wonderful and then there's
all these other little nuggets that we
get that are just setting up what we're
gonna be looking at next season and it's
so exciting that I cannot possibly wait
and I'm gonna have to wait a year a year
the stuff with bran up north and the
wall finally pays off I mean there's
still a lot more to be told with that
clearly but it really felt like they
were stretching that storyline out for a
while I was really intrigued by it I get
the sense a lot of people were just
bored and weren't enjoying it which I
get cuz it was just taking so long to
get anywhere well it got somewhere I old
boy did it ever Jon Snow I like where
he's going Stannis finally shows up
again and does something after sitting
on his butt at the iron bank for I don't
know five six episodes huh I don't even
know how long it was and didn't Aris
continues to have to make increasingly
hard choices life seems pretty easy for
her before she was going to amass
army and take everything over well life
ain't that straightforward and it's not
that easy she's learning that and it's
giving her a lot of death she could have
just been this vague Messiah figure but
no she's got layers and she's got
serious issues to have to deal with and
cope with I feel like I have to stop
there cuz if I keep going I'm gonna get
into spoilers so that's gonna be it for
this one it was an amazing season Val I
can't wait for the next one now I gotta
talk about spoilers so tune in for my
series overview spoiler filled so until
I get back this council is adjourned